bonjour philippe viroulais merci
beaucoup d'être en direct ce matin dans
la matinale verte et france alors c'est
un enjeu extrêmement important la
livraison des documents électoraux
français 48 millions d'électeurs une
bonne partie qui n'a pas reçu ces
documents
le gouvernement qui a donc fait appel à
la société adrexo pour les acheminer
visiblement il ya eu quelques problèmes
est-ce que vous pouvez nous les
expliquer il ya quand même une majorité
des français qui ont reçu la propagande
électorale avec sauna terre venait
d'ailleurs que sûr cette région là sur
l'ensemble de la france
donc on peut pas dire que le l'opération
n'ait pas été complètement vidé
effectivement des personnes ont pu
constater que la propagande n'avait pas
été distribués ou avaient été distribués
tardivement alors comment vous expliquer
ces retards ou ne fait que certains
électeurs n'ont pas reçu la propagande à
votre niveau en ce qui concerne les
retards ici pour la plupart des cas ils
ne sont pas différents fonctionnements
d'adrexo homes et hôpitaux au
fonctionnement en amour de la production
des plis qui sont arrivés relativement
tard dans les agences adrexo pour être
distribué en ce qui concerne la non
distribution ou pointant du doigt un
choix stratégiques de la direction qui a
été de recourir massivement à des
recrutements d'intérimaires plutôt que
d'employer le personnel fixe d'adrexo et
ce sont des personnes qui allaient
peut-être beaucoup de bonne volonté mais
qui n'étaient pas formés qui ne
connaissait pas notre métier de la
distribution et qui sont arrivés avec
des voitures personnelles le plein
depuis sur des communes qui ne
connaissaient pas forcément très bien
avec des plans souvent assez imprécis et
oui beaucoup de mal à exécuter cette
mission sur le terrain
problème qui n'est pas nouveau
chez chez adrexo c'est un problème
récurrent serait due dans l'appel
d'offres est ce que là elle le fait que
la société puisse le faire a été
soulevée ou pas est-ce que adrexo avait
déjà fait ce type de distribution ou pas
c'est la première fois qu'elle réaction
intervenait pour une opération de
distribution propagande électorale
puisque c'est la première année que le
marché qui habituellement était à 100 %
affecté à l'opérateur historique de
traitement du courrier en france a été
séparée en deux parties à l'ex régime
habituel donc attribuer avec sow donc
c'est la première fois que ce type
d'opération était mené par les
entreprises mais structurellement c'est
une entreprise qui a dix sept mille
salariés aux distributeurs mais qui sont
tous à temps partiel avec des contrats
de douze ou quinze heures par semaine et
qui donc structurellement aurait eu du
mal à faire face à cette opération avec
ses seuls salariés
effectivement va obtenir des renforts
mais le problème qui a principalement de
la formation en tant que délégué
syndical à ce que vous aviez averti
l'entreprise qu'il fallait avoir des
personnes qualifiées en tout cas pour le
faire avec cette surcroît de travail
oui nous nous alertons et le début du
mois de mars sur cette situation
c'est une société où il ya un climat
social très difficile avec très peu
négociations et si tous une entreprise
qui est très fortement endetté avec
beaucoup de problèmes à l'intérieur par
rapport aux investissements qui sont
menées et donc nous avions effectivement
informé la direction de nos deux des
risques et surtout las du manque des
personnels et matériels qui a qui sont
inquiètes présents dans l'entreprise
finalement le fait que votre entreprise
adrexo soit à la une des médias à cause
de ces couacs est-ce que ça va améliorer
les choses selon vous alors ce qui est
sûr c'est que les salariés permanents
d'avril sous sont choqués par cette
présence dans les médias s'y résout ce
sont des gens qui chaque semaine
on distribue la publicité de façon assez
remarquables sont très investis ce sont
des gens qui ont des emplois qui sont
souvent des compléments d'activité à
temps partiel et qui donc ont besoin de
ces emplois pour faire soit complément
d'activité ou un complément de
rémunération de retraite et ils sont
vraiment aujourd'hui monté à avoir après
avoir pourtant bien travaillé de leur
côté mais sacrément être victime d'un
choix stratégiques de la direction
est ce que vous êtes dans la course
c'est bien le moins pour pour le second
tour il va falloir redistribuer les
nouvelles listes aux électeurs de faire
un deuxième tour donc le s'organisent
les piles sont pas encore arrivées dans
les agences doivent arriver jeudi la
distribution se fera vendredi et samedi
donc dans un délai extrêmement court
et encore plus court que les délais que
nous avions eu pour le premier tour et
hélas du coup vous avez des renforts
alors effectivement il y à quelques
renforts avec de nouvelles sociétés de
travail temporaire qui se sont
manifestés pour soutenir des candidats
mais là encore nous allons avoir eu un
problème de formation
donc il va falloir pour les permanents
redoubler d'efforts pour que cette
opération du deuxième tour soit une
réussite donc tout au tout le réseau est
mobilisée avec les salariés permanents
mais aussi les distributeurs qui sont
disponibles sur cette partie de la
semaine
gerber maintenant est auditionné ce
matin devant la commission des lois du
sénat
est-ce que vous pensez que l'exécutif
aussi aurait peut-être dû mieux regarder
en faisant appel à une entreprise pour
un enjeu aussi important voire justement
si tous les
toutes les mains étaient disponibles et
la logistique et elle était bien là pour
assurer le travail ou pas oui il ya une
étude technique du dossier qui n'a pas
forcément été menée complètement la
faisabilité d'une telle opération sur
cette région avec un territoire sont
souvent difficiles notamment en zone
rurale
c'est vraiment une opération très
compliquée à mener et les techniques du
dossier lorsqu'il ya eu l'appel d'offres
a sûrement l'étude on a parlé de
bulletins brûler également et est ce que
vous confirmez des piles de bulletins
qui ont été brûlés c'est cette
anecdotique il y a eu quelques bulletins
qui ont pu être retrouvés ici et là en
france soit proche de 22.2 déchetterie
de poubelles brûlées c'est butin et ses
enveloppes ont mis en distribution
lorsque ça a été constaté mais c'est
vraiment peu significatif à l'échelle de
la france ce n'est pas vraiment merci
beaucoup en tout cas fille les viroulais
de nous avoir livré quelques
explications justement sur ce retard et
c'est non livraison dans certaines dans
certaines boîtes aux lettres des
lecteurs pour ce premier tour en
espérant que ça s'améliore pour le
second merci beaucoup